hi there Steve Kaufman of linked but
today I don't want to talk about
languages I kind of beaten that subject
to death somewhat as you know I'm a
great believer that anyone can learn
languages and I've devoted a fair amount
of my time to learning languages and to
offering free advice to people on how to
learn languages and I will continue
doing that but I also like to expound on
other things that you know world events
and things of that nature and today I
want to talk a bit about the Pope's
statement on capitalism and I mean I'm
not gonna read the whole thing I've got
it here in front of me but the gist of
it is that capitalism I mean the overall
impression creative created is that
capitalism but capitalism is bad sort of
control it breeds inequality inequality
breeds violence it's inherently unfair
that some people have a lot and other
people have less and so this was this
general gist of his message and of
course a lot of people immediately chime
in to agree with the Pope and so forth
let me say to get my conclusions up
front I completely disagree with the
Pope I'm reading an interesting book
right now by a person called Steven
Pinker and he catalogs with reference to
a number of in-depth studies he catalogs
that decline of violence and it's
absolutely astounding to the extent to
which violence in our societies has
declined over the last hundred years 200
years there have been exceptions there
have been exceptions like the first and
second world wars but even with that the
level of violence that in most parts of
the world that we experience is far far
lower than it was five hundred years ago
four hundred three hundred years ago so
I suggest that people read this book
it's called something like the better
angels of our nature and I again can't
remember all of the arguments but it's
obvious in that book that things like
democracy like capitalism have
contributed to this massive decline in
violence
and if you read you know the things that
the Pope is talking about how capitalism
creates inequality creates violence well
what what is this other Golden Age that
he is referring to perhaps it was the
period when religion held sway and there
pinker catalogues the incredible
instruments of torture that the Catholic
Church and not probably only the
Catholic Church but which were used in
the name of religion to to torture with
unspeakable cruelty people who are
considered to be you know heretics or
who weren't toeing the party line and so
forth and and if we look at you know
regimes where ideology has held sway
like Mao's China or Stalin's Russia or
Hitler's Germany
wherever ideology takes over we have
higher level levels of violence where
people are concerned about making money
and it's not through some unselfish of
motivation that the capitalist improves
the living standard of other people it's
because you have in a properly
functioning capitalist society you have
the opportunity to own the means of
production you can start a company you
can start producing things you can
compete with others others can compete
with you so rather than a society where
you have the king or the high priest or
the knight that can charge around and
lop off heads at will you know or lead
his gang of thugs into war at will which
was the situation that prevailed
everywhere in the world in primitive
societies as Pinker points out in Europe
in Asia where small scale battles
large-scale battles the willingness to
resort to violence to settle disputes
everything was much criminality was much
higher in previous centuries
and the decline the decline in this
violence the improvement in our
standards of living the improvement in
the health standards longevity
even in countries like India and China
all owes its origin to the expansion of
capitalism because you can actually see
it from the end of the 18th century you
see this granted there were excesses and
there was child labor and so forth but
the overall trend from that period on
has been dramatic improvement in the
standard of living in fact only since
then have living standards in the world
improved prior to that people lived at
subsistence levels whenever there was a
famine in one area everyone died not
everyone died but a high percentage of
people died there were vast epidemics
many children were born most of them
died and and now through the evil
pharmaceutical industry and all these
other evil industries we in fact have a
better standard of living that doesn't
mean that there aren't excesses of
commercialism there aren't aspects of
commercialism that we all find
distasteful but it is less damaging less
violent less detrimental to the quality
of human life more people in China today
live at a better standard of living and
in India that they did then they did say
in the case of China when they were
under Mao and at the whim of one leader
he could condemn a million people to die
in different campaigns in the 50s or on
some harebrained scheme of smelting all
the utensils and and so forth in back
yard iron smelters and therefore
neglecting what the business should have
been doing the result was that 40 50
million people died I mean let's get
serious
capitalism worked now that's not to say
that they said it shouldn't be regulated
and I personally find it appalling that
that executives in some companies make
you know 20 million dollars a year when
their workforce makes 50 thousand and
there was a
a referendum in Switzerland to limit the
how much money senior executives could
make and it was voted out but I have
some sympathy with that perspective I
think it's it's it's obscene that they
make so much money in that's--it's and
it is an old boys club and there's lots
of injustice in the world there's no
question that the senior executives who
sit on the boards and get paid obscene
amounts of money to sit on boards and
approve these high salaries for their
friends and stuff this there's great
inequality but it was ever so I mean
there was great and Mao had now his you
know harem of women and did whatever he
pleased in the 19th or 18th and 17th
century like 50% of the country's GDP
was was was basically consisted of the
consumption of the quart of the of the
you know the royal court I mean this is
just the if you compare the day we you
know today's social and economic
conditions with just about any other
period in history we are better off
today and that's what the Pope kind of
kind of loses sign up that there may be
excesses in capitalism there are
certainly excesses in the various
religions human beings are very
imperfect beings but in terms of
creating wealth improving standards of
living improving standards of health
providing more food for people the
capitalism has been a phenomenally
positive force and I am far less
skeptical and suspicious of someone who
wants to make money than I am of someone
who is promoting his ideology or his
religion at me because I have found that
a lot of the idealists become so wrapped
up in their ideals that all means are
justified by their great belief in their
ideal where as a businessman he's out to
make money and he has to compete in the
market and I prefer that so I just
thought I would offer these words which
I'm sure
assent but set the cat amongst the
pigeons as they say
and I look forward to your comments by
which I suspect will consist of a lot of
negative comments and a lot of thumbs
down because people are taught at school
that profit is bad that businesspeople
are bad and that somehow you know people
who are not into business are better and
it's always been that way throughout
history the the the producers and the
merchants that that trade and create the
wealth were always considered bad
whereas the knight who killed people and
the religious person who persecuted
people and the king who had this
unlimited conspicuous consumption they
were all good
so it's ever it was ever thus I don't
know why it is it's probably there's a
probably an evolutionary explanation but
trade is good reciprocity is good and it
beats idealism in the long run thanks
for listening bye for now